thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another careful boys we
are indeed very careful boys today we
are going to talk about Nick because
Nick had made a return to fighting let's
go
it's not really fighting after promising
his sense and he would never do it you
said you'd never do it again you put
that on the weapons forever did you win
Nick had a Jujitsu competition I just
didn't just talk about it dude I
wouldn't even tell us you [ __ ] because
there's none of your [ __ ] business
dude I didn't even tell my own wife
after the tournament my wife calls me
and she goes hey I'm like hey she goes
um so you competed when I go yeah I
didn't want to tell you why because we
we had a crazy weekend we went to the
Bad Bunny concert the night before which
was crazy
but why'd you even go to bed it's not
like distract you or like if I if I'm
tired and I go compete I should be able
to perform either way no matter what not
if you're going up against this killer
you need everything but that's why I got
[ __ ] second place so it don't matter
I mean I shouldn't have gone but I got
some I got some good [ __ ] sleep that
night but because the concert was so lit
doesn't your uh wife go like uh she
can't tell that you've been ramping up
or training like crazy in preparation
all like like when you're slamming her
and breaking her back and stuff she's
like I'm Paul driving her dude like
suplexer uh no because I've been
teaching a lot more since the academy
has been open because we opened up uh
the gym has been opened up called
Lionheart Jiu Jitsu Academy I own it she
owns it colleens Colleen's the main
owner in Pasadena yeah so we opened up a
new location of Hawaii coming soon next
to shout out to Jeremy shout out to
Jeremy shout out to my boy Jeremy
zergami he's the owner the founder but
uh we've been teaching uh classes over
there and we've just been training way
more so it just so happened where I was
like [ __ ] it I'm gonna sign up for this
tournament a couple of guys are gonna
compete we might as well try to build a
competition team because we're like
pretty brand new Squad so I was like
[ __ ] it let's just go let's go test
ourselves and see where we're at what's
the structure of the tournament how many
people are you up against how do you
even get it depends so because I turned
30 I have officially entered the Masters
division
yeah so it's just for 30 and up and [ __ ]
so can we call you master now or is that
like not cool do I have to call you
master that's not okay you call me
[ __ ] Nick dude call me China Nick is
what some of my well some of my friends
is it the white guys that are called
Masters that call you China nick uh Ryan
calls me China Nick okay got it I just
wanted to competed in the Masters
Division I could be the Masters division
so it's like a usually a smaller bracket
and then also too like the high this is
my first competition probably in like
three years maybe so I haven't competed
in a while the last time competed I
performed like dog [ __ ] so I was like I
gotta run that back
uh and then the pandemic happened so
whatever but this is the first time I
felt like really excited to compete I
felt like prepared so I was like [ __ ] it
how long did you prepare for this one
was about a month so not that long about
four or like four weeks you don't care
about this [ __ ] huh hey when your boy
trying to seven days a week you know how
many people do you have to beat to win
uh so our bracket was only four guys so
it wasn't that big so it depends on how
many people show up so literally it's
like two and two and then that's it
finals yeah yeah okay so the guy the
first guy who went up against how did
that match go started real slow I kind
of I'm breaking down like a sports
commentator so yeah even though we can't
watch so for this tournament I wanted to
really be
I felt like I needed to like conquer my
nerves a little bit because I tend to
when I compete I'm really on the far
side of just like being crazy and kind
of wild
um so I wanted to be a little slower
play Pace I tend to have a more
wrestling dominant game so I try to get
on top try to take people down and then
stay on top this time I wanted to start
from the bottom my coach was like Hey
you start they call pulling guard which
is funny because you sit to your butt
and you're like yeah so that's pulling
guard so I decided to pull guard this
time and
so you did one of those things that we
always joke around about where to start
to fight you like whatever thing you're
like
I I put my foot up on his hip it's
called pulling guard so when you pull a
guard you want to step up and pull him
towards you and I've never done that in
a competition before I usually try to go
for takedowns so I kind of [ __ ] up
actually I kind of my foot slipped I was
like oh [ __ ] and I slipped and you
pulled them on top of you yeah but I was
in a guard he didn't pass my guard or
anything but um passing guard is like
when you score points so if you get past
my legs and you get to a position where
your chest gets on my chest and you're
kind of perpendicular to me laying on
top of me that's when you score points
so when you have a partner in front of
you you want to keep your feet in front
so then it makes it easier for you to do
moves flip them over their head all that
fun stuff like sweeps so I started
really slow I think I was actually too
slow I felt a little too like chill
actually why oh because you're in that
mindset like I want to do this yeah I
want to be calmer I kind of want but I
was a little I think I was a little too
slow
a little bit
not really sometimes it's like that dude
you go because like there people come
from different walks of life right so
some dudes it's like California guys
yeah I train hard in the gym so I just
come here and just kind of test my
skills some other guy it's like just my
whole self-worth is here in Marietta
okay yeah and then they just go crazy
you know like cool [ __ ] chill out dude
so you do get opposands of the spectrum
too and it's like so
I'm a brown belt now so this is a brown
belt competition a lot of these guys
everyone's pretty badass they're trying
to get to the black belt level so they
they want to have a good point that's
that's what I want to do too I want to
test myself so
um yeah I felt like I was a little too
chill I probably could have pushed the
pace a little bit more I ended up
winning the first match by points so I
won by like scoring a couple points did
you give that kind of your card and go I
teach I should have oh I should have but
everyone's really cool though because
everyone's like we're like chatting
before the comp they're like hey we
shake hands blah blah so it's cool and
then we had the final
um I went against this dude he was like
a wrestler guy and I deviated from the
game plan I [ __ ] up
the guy scored some points early on me
what was your game behind a [ __ ] pole
guard again I was I was gonna wrestle
with him I was gonna try to wrestle all
but I I was I should have pulled guard I
should have that's what I should have
done I didn't do that
um and because I tried to wrestle with
them I made a tactical error got points
scored on me early and then when that
happens sometimes you get me like he
passed your guard or he yeah he Pat he
took me down but it was like kind of
like a scramble but he got points for
taking me down
um so he did get he scored like Five
Points back to back so Five Points off
the Jump so now you're on tilt yeah now
I'm 5-0 and I'm like I look at the clock
and I remember thinking like [ __ ] I'm
down five so already mentally you kind
of [ __ ] with yourself a little bit and
then in my head instead of trying to get
those points back I was like oh I gotta
try to finish him I gotta stop his ass
yeah I gotta try to but I had like
[ __ ]
four minutes on the clock so not that
much time but still enough time to get
some points back so yeah I think with my
headspace I was a little like a little
iffy and I wasn't making the best
decisions but I almost scored a couple
times I got some points back but then he
ended up beating me do you feel like you
would have made better decisions if you
like didn't go out to Bad Bunny the
night before no I think that was
regardless honestly I honestly felt like
that concert actually helped me a little
bit yeah it was a great concert it was
an amazing concert have you seen them
live is amazing let's focus on your
fight have you guys been to Sofi Stadium
by the way I have not been yet Sofi
stadium is [ __ ] huge as [ __ ] right
insane dude really it's so cool but
anyways uh back to the tournament so uh
I lost all points I felt like I could
beat him honestly in my head I felt like
I just ran out of time was he bigger
than you uh he might have been he might
have been but similar to weight class
right yeah so we're in a weight range so
like 167 pounds and below so as long as
you're within like 155 to 167 with a
Geon you're you're good how do you how
do you make these like tactical game
plan like decisions like for example in
your first fight you're like I like
never pull guard yeah but then in the
second one you're like I should have
pulled guard like how you know what I
mean because because my coach going into
this these this tournament he was like
play your guard so also like he told you
and then you deviated from like your
coach's plan exactly based on like info
about the opponent or is it just like a
little bit a little bit of that and then
also based on what my coach sees in the
gym so he's like what's your strength
yeah and he's like hey you've been
working on this recently so we might as
well just test it out let's see it let's
like you you it's he said it's been
giving me a hard time so I feel like
you'll give these guys a hard time so so
play this game so so if your coach tells
you to do that but then you deviate like
how do you expect your students to like
listen to you and say but that's what it
is question that's what that's why you
go out there and compete you got to test
it you got to see where you're at when
you when you guys when you're under that
pressure you will make dumbass mistakes
like I was having conversations with our
class telling them like hey when this X
Y and Z happens then in competition you
might [ __ ] up and I was and I went
through the same [ __ ] and then you're
like see yeah that's good all right then
again it's like it's it's just fixing uh
fixing that stuff for the future that's
what it really comes down to and that's
why that's cool well it's a tactical
decision to wrestle the second one I
kind of got my own head did your coach
tell you to do that no so coach wanted
to pull guard the whole time yeah but in
my head I was like uh I saw him wrestle
and I was worried that my guard wasn't
going to be good enough to be able to
deal with his wrestling and then once we
started
competing enrolling each other I
realized I was like I [ __ ] up I should
have pulled off from the beginning
because I would have had him on the
offensive like in my head when I was
watching to compete I felt like I broke
him from on my back just trying to like
get attempts he was getting tired he was
kind of gassing out and he just
outlasted you know on the on the points
but in my head I was like if I had a
little bit more time I could have got on
for sure dude do you guys talk to each
other in there like when you're in that
huddle like [ __ ] wrapped up with each
other sometimes sometimes the fear the
Diaz brothers you do the guy he kind of
did gesture to me because he had me in a
position and I was kind of waiting a
little bit to see where it was and it
probably wasn't a good place for me to
wait but he kind of looked at me and was
like
as if are you gonna do something you
know but I was just kind of seeing what
was going to happen but I remember him
and I was like oh that's new I've never
seen anybody do that before
but I I did feel very this time around I
did feel very present in the moment like
competing which is something
that I don't really feel typically so I
was like okay that's good I think
mentally I'm trying to build up to be
able to compete more often and then you
know just try to fine-tune and not worry
about necessarily that's totally
different from where you were which is
cool but you know what I mean like from
the idea of like you not competing
anymore not fighting suddenly you're
like yeah I'm trying to build up and
compete I'm like oh [ __ ] and that's what
it was I felt I felt cool I felt this is
the first time ever I felt like excited
I was like nervous obviously but I felt
excited to compete and I was like no I
want to see where I'm at like usually
I'm kind of like oh [ __ ] I don't know
geez what am I gonna do but this time in
my head I was like I kind of want to
smoke a little bit I want to see who the
best guy is and I want to compete
against them and usually
I tend to be like not on that side of
the spectrum I'm always like worried and
I kind of psych myself out especially
when there's a guy who's really good and
I'm like [ __ ] am I gonna be good enough
that guy has 19 000 Instagram balls yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah like because you
play these games when you're when you're
with your silence I do and that's
something I want to get better at not
doing so the only way to do that is just
to kind of compete more so yeah we'll
see what happens what about your other
student Marlin did he do pretty good he
did great
um and that was the other thing too
watching a bunch of our guys use the
system and apply the things that we've
been teaching and doing it on the best
guys in their bracket as white belts and
winning their divisions and comp doing
everything like textbook while other
guys that they were beating were just
kind of like they didn't know what the
[ __ ] to do and I was like man this is
cool it kind of got me hyped up seeing
all the younger guys do their things our
school is better than your school well
kind of that's the game right that's the
game it's like it's like can you because
there's so many different positions in
the in and Jiu Jitsu so you want to see
who's well-rounded enough to handle
these positions and everybody plays a
different type of position everyone's
strengths are always different so it's a
lot of it will be a battle of styles of
like oh he's a top guy he's a delaheeva
player whatever the case may be so to be
able to have that Swiss army knife
ability to to to change on the Fly and
to deal with the threats that are coming
at you is a really cool thing and then
to see it from the guys who are white
belts we've only been training like less
than a year and they're already applying
it to guys who you could tell are
towards the end of their Wipeout career
where they're about to be
white belt to blue belt and our guys are
just starting and they're they're
beating these guys and they're doing it
with technique and with a little bit of
sauce you know and it's cool to see so
it got me pretty hyped up and I'm
excited for what what happens in the
academy because everyone's doing a good
job so oh yeah I'm excited too because I
own the place yeah yeah so it's good for
it we're ripping the name right all
right Colleen so now I have to ask the
stupid question yeah are you trying to
be in UFC bro
dude no way no way because that's a
different game that's a different game
completely what happens if after your
fight some cool guy with a cigar in the
back goes your name Nick Dunn that's
Matthew McConaughey that's odd because
you're just getting started
oh [ __ ] what are you saying you don't
even be my agent I'll say that what do
you say it's like you need a new stage
name dick none and I was like that
actually is already taken I have a bunch
of emails under dick thank you you
wouldn't take an offer to start on that
track to fight like just to start on
that track of where it leads to that
you're gonna start wearing the rock
shoes you know yeah I'm out I don't know
you would have like what if like my dad
knows Dana White and I'm like hey dude
I'll get you a [ __ ] fight that would
be crazy would you be down if there was
like so I think if there was some sort
of Fast Track like I'm gonna put you on
[ __ ] pay-per-view Logan Paul right
away You're gonna be at right away you
just get one because that's like a
bucket list for a lot of mm it's like
it's like Rocky right like like GSP is
looking for a [ __ ] ringer yeah
yeah I think it'd have to be the right
matchup if anything but yeah we'll give
you one fight yeah I don't know I think
I'm so far away from actually thinking
about fighting in MMA because to me Jiu
Jitsu is one thing right but then MMA is
a whole nother [ __ ] beast well let's
take the actual stuff out it's like hey
you go down in the third ring you get
fifteen thousand dollars you taking it
or not and you have it and you go down
in the third round it's just a [ __ ]
you just get you just gotta last and
just go downstairs yeah take a fall yeah
dude it's mob brand UFC dude I'll take a
fall on the third round if I could
[ __ ] last the third round yeah for 15
grand that's the real [ __ ] thing I
might follow the first one yeah I might
get kayode you gotta last until the
third round that's pretty hard huh it
depends on who the matchup is yeah it's
a guy with a sword oh [ __ ] it's Joe dude
if I have to fight Joe with the katana
I'm [ __ ] diving on it so actual
question why didn't you tell us about it
and why didn't you tell your wife about
it whoa piece of [ __ ] I just I did tell
you guys about it and how does she feel
about you wanting to compete more often
she I don't think she know that oh she
does she she knows that you told us a
long time ago but it was very indefinite
you were like I think yeah why didn't
you tell your wife that's so weird
because I just didn't want her to worry
maybe it's my own [ __ ] but I just didn't
want her yeah it is um I just didn't
want her to worry or stress out over it
because that tends to happen and then
why would she worry about it because
she's seen me get my eyes beat in front
of her eyes she thinks you're gonna get
CTE yeah
you just want to see her though yeah and
also too it's like an all day thing bro
the last thing you want to do after you
go to like a a rager of a concert is to
[ __ ] be in a gym a high school smelly
gym that's an hour and a half away on a
Sunday you know like she got well how
many hours total was this event that you
were it was like an all-day thing but we
probably got like eight hours we were
probably there for like five hours I got
there at 12. you think all belts left at
five within all belts it's all age
groups yeah so it's a [ __ ] long but
it's cool though because it's like a
small community so you see people that
you haven't seen and is it fun to watch
every single match yeah it is and it's
cool because you see somebody's like
these younger kids who are just doing
the craziest [ __ ] like the future is
going to be so bright in Jiu Jitsu
because the the level of Education that
everyone's getting is just at such a
higher level like when I first started
to do Jiu Jitsu back in the day like we
were looking at like books of pictures
of like step by step how to do all these
moves but now you have the Buddhist palm
yeah like [ __ ] pen flips and now you
have the greatest coaches in the world
guys like you no greatest coaches in the
world putting out uh master classes yeah
master classes and instructionals and
they become the industry standard for a
lot of people in the game do you think
Lionheart Jiu Jitsu has a rival School
[Laughter]
no I think not really necessarily a
rival But like everyone we have friendly
actually what's the friend yeah what's
the friendly
there's a bunch of gyms people like
territorial like they if you're
interested if you're territorial you're
a loser first off
you're a loser like shut up there's
enough to eat for everybody yeah you're
in the Jitsu Community kind of like
knows each other so like even though
there's we have a lot of good friends
that train at the gym down the street we
have a lot of people that train up the
street like we know everyone it's it's a
tight-knit community we're all chill you
know how about like a personal rival for
you is there somebody out there in the
in the community is there a guy named
like Brad the nose or some [ __ ] or a gym
what about in in your gym is there one
that's like you're like oh man that guy
first [ __ ] I got a second yeah you're
like low-key like you're next how come
when you get second it sounds cool but
when he gets second sounds like [ __ ]
well he earned him I was hoping I was
hoping me and Anthony could like relate
and bond over it and it would be me and
Anthony against the rest of you guys I'm
just wondering if Steve's ever competed
in anything and knows what that feels
like I actually won uh everything I've
ever done
I gave up competition because it's just
too easy yeah it's too easy it's like
it's like it's a cake
I hope we get out on time today can you
can you let us know though when you're
gonna fight next yeah you [ __ ] all
right dude don't yell at me bro share
your [ __ ] Google Calendar with us I
would love to I would love to actually
see you taking something seriously I
think that would be really fun I think
even in the match like that I did I kind
of
I was a little too chill could I be our
psychiatrist for a second yeah tell me I
kind of feel like that like it's too
much pressure to take something serious
so if you feel like if you don't commit
100 if it's only 80 or 90 then if you
fail you're like well I didn't give him
my Hundred you don't fall back on that
well I didn't take it seriously so your
boy was trying to hard for this I was
getting [ __ ] rounds dude the one of
the [ __ ] were you wrestling in the
second one because I I psyched myself
the first one
yeah you're listening to a champion yeah
yeah he's the first place
in the first one yeah because I don't
know I think I think one of the main
things for me is like battling the
inside the yeah up here so like that's
the reason why I want to compete more so
I can [ __ ] I actually like the idea
of you in the mid-match and then you
start deviating and you just hear your
coach in the background going oh Nick
why did you do
I don't think I did feel like really
remote I was really disappointed
afterwards I was really disappointed I
was like I was really upset
um but like what maybe even more like
[ __ ] it's just because my coach was like
Coach Joe teodoro he's my guy he goes
he's like Nicki you should have beat
those guys he's like you should have
beat that last guy and that's all you
had to say
was he there yeah he was there he was
coaching and he's like he's like it's
okay he's coaching from Zoom yeah yeah
yeah
he's like hand it over that was cool too
no Joe's he's one of the best dudes ever
and he's a guy that I look up to a lot
because he's he's just a g because he
goes out there he competes and he has
that [ __ ] and he Rex full he Rex
fools dude yeah I'm playing all soft and
[ __ ] and if I want to be on his level I
gotta [ __ ] learn from my guy you know
so but at the same time it is like one
of those things where oh right when he
said it I was like
because it's more about that like I want
to you know right represent for him
because he's the one spending time and
he's the one spending all those extra
hours yeah wasting his time on his
[ __ ] nonsense idiot over here isn't
crazy just a couple words cuts the
deepest it's like you shouldn't beat
those guys just that simple it's like
but everybody was like oh
yeah yeah Steve sometimes words cut deep
I don't know what you mean
yeah
all right